earlier this year the World Health
Organization warned that new diseases
could spread in the wake of the deadly
SARS virus immunologist Eleanor lady
chronicles developments over the last 30
years in her new book the new killer
diseases this talk from brookline
booksmith in massachusetts is an hour
tonight we welcome respected
immunologist eleanor levy for a
discussion of her new book the new
killer diseases how the alarming
evolution of mutant genes mute and germs
threatens us all in the last three
decades researchers have discovered more
than 30 new infectious diseases
including AIDS Lyme disease West Nile
virus and most recently SARS which
happened to emerge just as Eleanor and
Mark were completing this book and is
responsible for the new introduction
researchers have also been alarmed by
the recent reemergence and more
dangerous forms of scourge is such as TB
and the west and the bubonic plague with
the new killer diseases Eleanor levy
provides us with vital facts for that we
must know about the astonishing range of
these new threats inside are gripping
and at times of big gruesome accounts of
personal stories of flushing diseases in
the cases of West Nile in a detailed
fashion this timely an important book
reveals the way that these new DS is
manifest themselves the symptoms to
watch out for and how to get a correct
diagnosis in time elderly he holds a PhD
in biophysics and as a post doctoral
training and immunology she specializes
in HIV and AIDS research and teaches me
knology at Boston University School of
Medicine she is the author of many
scientific articles and the ten best
tools to boost your meant your immune
system please help me welcome Eleanor
levy
thank you all for coming and I want to
thank mark and brookline booksmith for
hosting this event and this is my first
book signing so hopefully it'll all go
well I'm going to start out well the
whole title of this book is the new
killer diseases why SARS West Nile Ebola
and mad cow or only the beginning and
then at the bottom it says how the
alarming evolution of mutant germs
threatens us all what I was planning to
do is to start out reading little and
talking a little about the chapters one
at a time see how much time we I have to
go through all of that and at some point
if you have a burning question that you
want to answer I hope we can keep it
reasonably informal and you can
interrupt if you if you want to or at
the end we're going to leave time for
discussion so whichever way works better
for you all it's fine with me okay so
let me start I'm going to skip the
Czar's introduction which we wrote at
the very last minute but people get back
to it briefly some other later point and
before I forget I also want to mention
that my son developed a wonderful
website same name as the book the new
killer diseases calm and it it lets you
link to all kinds of good sites for
getting up-to-date information like the
World Health Organization if you want to
know what's going on with SARS there's a
link that goes to that immediately to
the Czar's page and saves you you know a
lot of looking around and it very easy
to use I'm sure you'll find things there
make it worthwhile for you to look it up
so let me start out with the gruesome
story that Richard was talking about
chapter one starts with the case of
Jeannie Brown as the case of SARS
demonstrates the human races in the
midst
of an escalating biological war against
an army of microscopic foes that we have
seriously underestimated these
infectious microbes are ought inspiring
a number and are stunningly resilient
they can reproduce in hours or even
minutes mutating and adapting far faster
than we humans can they are learning to
outmaneuver our immune systems and our
drugs they are rapidly involving deadly
new capabilities there is really no way
to keep these pathogens out of our homes
or workplaces the threat they pose is as
formidable as any of the human race has
ever faced and despite all our brilliant
advances in science pharmaceuticals and
medical technology these simple
organisms could still get the better of
us we have no idea when the next Ebola
virus or mad cow disease might emerge in
our backyard or when some ordinary
microbe might swap genes with a deadly
germ to create a super pathogen even
more very virulent and quickly spreading
than aids on any given day one of these
mutant diseases might strike down any
one of us or someone we love so we must
teach ourselves had to be on high alert
for these diseases can be terribly
deceptive just as SARS mimics a cold or
the flu in its early stages other new
killers can fool patients and doctors
into overlooking their danger and then
we get into the story of Jeannie Brown
Jeannie Brown was a woman in her 30s
living in i think it was north carolina
and one day she noticed she was raising
a ten-year-old son by yourself one day
she was just noticing that her shoulder
was aching and she was supposed to go to
beach with some friends and she did go
to the beach but she was decided she
couldn't stay here so shoulder was
bothering her too much so she came home
the next day it was feeling even worse
and so she went to see a doctor who said
you know maybe she pulled something was
by this time first day there was nothing
to show that there was anything wrong
but second day was getting red and a
little bit swollen she went to the
doctors and maybe pulled something I
don't know you know here's some pain
pills sends her home
the next day she's now throwing up
violently she's shoulders becoming the
pain is traveling it's extending she's
black and blue and it's swollen and she
now goes one of the jobs that she has
she's working two jobs one of them is at
a doctor's office an orthopedist this
was not a good choice of somebody to see
so she goes to the office where she
works it takes her two hours to get
there would think normally would take
her 20 minutes because she has to keep
on stopping to throw up she gets there
and the doctor says you know maybe you
were at the beach maybe it's sunburned
you know here are some other pills to
take and you know why don't you go home
and rest by the next day I mean she is
now deathly ill and she called and she
knows that there's something seriously
wrong and this is not sunburn she calls
her sister-in-law who's a nurse who
comes over it takes one look at her and
says you know we have to call an
ambulance you have to get to the
hospital now and what makes this story
so meaningful to me is she then says I
don't want to make a fuss I'm not sure
we should do this so the sister-in-law
calls her mother to convince her that
they really need to call an ambulance at
this point they get her to the hospital
and by this point her kidneys are
failing her her heart is is having
problems I mean she's just shutting down
doctor doesn't know what's wrong with
her she's now black and blue all over
her body they think maybe she's been
beaten but no maybe she's done something
with her medications know whatever it is
the doctor recognizes it's more than he
can deal with and he gets her sent to a
larger hospital and she has her heart
fails soon after getting there and
that's the end of the story they didn't
realize it was an infection until the
autopsy and what it turned out to be was
invasive Group A streptococcus as strap
is you know all of you are familiar with
strep throat and strep is extremely
common organism rarely it becomes invade
and one of the things that's so scary
about this is nobody knows the
difference between the invasive strains
and then the strings that mostly just
colonizes mostly it's you know millions
of people carry strap and it just you
know sort of lives in your nose or your
throat doesn't bother you at all but it
may be 10 to 20,000 cases a year it
becomes invasive and in most of those
cases it sort of stays within the lungs
or it can cause what it's called does
flesh-eating bacteria kind of thing
where it starts eating away causing
flesh to necrosis and then in some cases
it causes what Jeannie Brown had which
is this toxic shock syndrome and you
know when our editor first heard the
story she said you know those doctors
you know they should have done better
they know the doctor don't know what
they're doing there there wasn't
anything very specific to give it away
it's so rare that and it's and it
doesn't spread very readily from one
person to another it's altogether
unknown why one person will get this
horrendous disease and you know hurtin
third sister-in-law who took care of her
other people in the household her
neighbors nobody else got sick I mean
this was it's a very rare presentation
of a very common organism so it's it is
very easy to miss I mean and and of
course the fact that you went to an
orthopedist for infection what turned
out to be infection you know didn't help
her either and another very sad thing
about this is is that it's easily
treatable if somebody had recognized
what it was and just given her an
antibiotic early on she would have been
fine so I think this is probably our
scariest story if you you know are
looking for something terrifying I mean
I think this is it this is just out of
nowhere something that can get you that
is likely to be missed until it's too
late on six months later another woman
had a similar
she had read about Jeanne Brown she went
to the doctor early they said yeah well
maybe it is the same thing and you know
she lived to tell the story turned out
there was no connection between the two
women it was just this other spontaneous
case of the same sort of thing
so I mean that's essentially the issues
that we deal with in that chapter our
second chapter talks about bioterrorism
the bioterrorism challenge meeting the
threat and we start out talking about
anthrax we also talk about smallpox we
talk about the case of David hose who
was one of the postal workers who
survived inhalation anthrax it used to
be thought that inhalation anthrax was
invariably fatal anthrax exists new in
the environment it's something that
animals get it can exist in the soil for
a long time it was associated with
people who processed goat pelts but it
is one of the weapons that people can
use as a bioterrorist weapon and in its
normally what it do is cause skin
infections and those are generally
fairly easy treatable but when it's
inhaled which is not a usual thing to
happen it can be very deadly David hose
is one of it was thought that it was
invariably deadly but in this anthrax
outbreak that occurred not too long ago
I think sixty percent of people died but
forty percent of them did survive it but
hoes we used to be a big strapping
person who is to this day debilitated by
his bout with anthrax and it's not clear
whether it's affected his mind as well
as his body he's very depressed and his
doctors don't understand why he can't do
more than he seems to be able to do at
this point so these diseases are not
just bad for what they immediately do
but they can have even if you survive
them have
long-term consequences smallpox is a
another gridded bioterrorist weapon that
people are concerned about and we
discuss the dark winter exercise that
was orchestrated by the hob John Hopkins
civilian bio defense center or something
like that to give it was a computer
simulation of a smallpox attack to give
people an idea of what was involved in
such an attack what kind of preparation
where we're going to need what kind of
planning would have to occur and they
had people who were in government and
they had reporters playing people in the
media the National Security Council and
you know how would they respond when
they would these bits of information
would dribble out about so many people
are sick with what might be smallpox
here and then there and then they found
out how you know uncoordinated the
system was at that point and probably to
a large extent still is but I mean that
was that coupled with the anthrax attack
has just led to an enormous amount of
money now being spent to try and prepare
this country for bio terrorist attacks
but there's still a long way to go and
the the two things that areas that are
being worked on our detection and the
development of vaccines and house of
reps voted to approve 5.6 billion
dollars for project Bioshield to try and
improve this country's preparedness and
we talked about the the smallpox vaccine
and what's been involved in developing
that and the problems involved with
trying to get that given to first
responders who were more concerned about
the
side effects of that vaccine which is a
particularly dangerous vaccine then from
a potential attack which seemed
reasonably unlikely okay chapter three
chapter three talks about West Nile
virus which is very much with us again
this year I think Massachusetts had its
first case of the summer just this week
but it is going through the country and
there are over 400 cases that have been
reported and 10 deaths so far this
summer as compared to something like
4,000 cases last year but it's still
very early in the season I'll read you
just a little bit of the story this miss
chapter we follow the story of somebody
who was one of the first people in New
York to be infected with West Nile virus
in summer of nineteen ninety nine as as
daylight faded after dinner and Rico
would usually water the vegetable garden
or putter around fixing this or painting
that the only drawback was an occasional
mosquito bite but that was a small price
to pay for the pleasure of being outside
on this evening though Enrico wasn't
feeling well his head hurt he was having
chills and fever he swallowed two
aspirin tablets and went to bed his
fever got much worse overnight spiking
to nearly 104 degrees several times
interlaced with severe chills his
muscles quivered by the next morning his
limbs already aching began to become
rigid he found it hard to walk he called
in sick to work than his legs collapsed
under him in the kitchen Katrina
immediately phoned for help and an
ambulance rushed him to Flushing
hospital medical center by the time they
wheeled him into the emergency room and
Rico could not move his arms or legs at
all it was as if he were suddenly peril
eyes he also seemed disoriented and
confused and goes on to tell and Rico's
story again he's somebody who survived
but still has not been able to go back
to work yes oh dude can you just wait
for somebody to get him I it just your
book is entitled you know killer
diseases and I just wondering in terms
of the examples you're giving to the
extent of the numbers of people who've
died from West Nile is it typically
people who are otherwise healthy or is
the people who already have compromised
immune systems I mean you know to the
extent of the you know death that's
involved with it right and West Nile
tends to kill older people but not
necessarily ill people and it kills
people in their 50s as well as you know
60s and 70s and 80s so it you're more
likely to be killed by it if you're
older and that may have something to do
with the fact that immunity Blaine's as
you get older particularly up into your
70s but it isn't a disease that you have
to be compromised in order to get now
like many infections the vast majority
of people who become infected with West
Nile don't get this encephalitis which
is what kills people people get infected
and have no symptoms that they're aware
of or maybe they have a cold so for any
infectious agent there is a whole
spectrum of responses to an infection
just like a genie Browns it was an
unusual response to that infection so
it's it isn't a disease most of these
are not diseases that you have to be
particularly vulnerable to
get but most of them again will be
diseases that are more likely to be
fatal for the elderly for a number of
reasons it just strikes me that it's
somewhat of a hysteria or two for people
you know in terms of there's one case in
Massachusetts and this is a year where
it's been very wet so we've had a very
large mosquito you know population on
you know I just am having a hard time
with what really is you know when the
risk here I I do think you know general
healthiness of being outdoors and active
versus the risk of this disease you know
of catching you know being bitten by
mosquito that has this disease I think
there's a difference between hysteria
and preparedness so if you want to go
outside put on mosquito repellent that's
not you know particularly onerous thing
to do and it will protect you or you
know if you've got old tires or even a
bird bath and sitting there you know I
think you need to think about if you're
in an area that you know has the first
sign of West Nile being an area is that
bird start dying crows more than
anything else so if you know there have
been reports of dead crows in your area
you know well then you might think of
emptying a birdbath but in any case you
know empty containers that are sitting
around on your property that might breed
mosquitoes so I mean they said there's a
big difference between reacting
hysterically and reacting appropriately
and I think you know you need to figure
out what the appropriate responses
interestingly West Nile is more
prevalent in areas that it was not so
prevalent in last year I mean it moves
along so one of the reasons that I think
there are probably several reasons that
Massachusetts and New York are not
seeing a whole lot of West Nile where
it's originally they did part of it is
because people are taking precautions
because health departments are for all
the mosquitoes that are out there
they're still being very active you know
trying to kill mosquito larvae which is
much better way of doing it and trying
to spray
a and it could be that the birds means
killed off a lot of birds and other
birds become immune so it may be the
bird population that is now less
supportive of West Nile in this area I
mean that's speculation but that's a
possibility so depending you have to
sort of weigh the situation that we are
in in this community to make a decision
about you know how much this should
affect our lives yes West Nile is not a
new disease right it's brought over from
someplace else yes um where is endemic
are people more resistant to it and it's
just that we haven't been exposed to it
before or as it is deadly presumably in
Egypt or wherever came from West Nile
was more of a disease of birds and
animals in other countries and not so
much a disease of people there was a an
outbreak in Romania there was an
outbreak among geese remaining it was
among people in in Israel there was a I
think was geese that had an outbreak so
the way it's infecting people in this
country is somewhat new so although the
virus itself is not new this is a
somewhat new presentation people wonder
if it's a in some way you know it has
mutated to now infect people differently
or if it has more to do with the
ecological system that it now finds
itself in that it's more able to infect
people unknown yes
it seems like the common denominator for
all these is that not so much that the
diseases are new but people really
minimalize whatever symptoms they come
up with they tend to disregard that
anything's gone wrong wrong with them is
that something you're finding or that
the CDC deal deals with well I mean
Jeanie Brown is a perfect example of
somebody who minimized symptoms when she
couldn't I I think there's no both the
tendency to minimize and the tendency to
overreact depending on you know who you
are to start with and how these things
hit you but as far as something like
SARS that's a new disease that has not
been seen that anybody knows of on this
planet before in people a lot of these
diseases are organisms did cause
diseases and animals and now have begun
to infect people and that's part of
their ability to mutate and find a new
host system that you know give them this
advantage and now has a whole new host
of to spread around and so they're not
necessarily brand new some of them are
some of them are new in this country and
some are new people I think we used knew
a little bit loosely yes do we have any
ID do we have any idea how how long it
takes human immune systems to adapt to
new viruses or two new illnesses yeah
I'm immune systems for viruses mostly
there are different components to the
immune system for the for viruses mostly
it's know the specific immunity the T
cells that are important and it can take
several weeks usually takes at least 10
days for the immune system to for that
part of the immune system to kick in so
what we'll get to talk about
flew for flu it's very relevant this
dance that goes on between the immune
system and newly emerging variants of
flu that get around the immune system
immune system is very important in this
and when something new comes along it
does have a you know a whole population
that it now has a chance to infect where
after a while you know more people
become immune to it they get these
low-level infections and then they're
protected in the future yes I imagine
that your goal in in writing this book
was partly to educate people as to kind
of what's out there and what to look for
in terms of simple symptoms and I
imagine to that that's response to there
not being enough education out there
kind of filling filling a gap or need
and I was wondering what you think about
that that someone out there isn't kind
of doing their job properly or
appropriately or and why that might be
well I think in today's climate there's
a lot of attention paid to infectious
diseases and you know newspapers more
than anything else probably newspapers
radio spend time talking about new
outbreaks and so there there is you know
a certain amount of education that comes
that way the CDC I think it used to be
more involved in educating physicians
people in health care community and they
didn't even necessarily do that very
well and I think anthrax has changed
that a lot showed up a lot of weaknesses
in the system so that now the CDC has a
wonderful website you know if you're
interested then it breaks it down for
for healthcare providers you know
technical information and frequently
asked questions and it has a lot of
useful information so that if people are
interested me that takes their
going out and doing looking for it but
you know there is a lot of information
there yes what's your opinion on the
reaction to the sars outbreak like how
do you think it went the reaction yeah
um well that's that's a big question
SARS is an example of a disease where
things worked very well some people are
concerned that there was an overreaction
to us you know again in this country it
never amounted to anything but in Canada
it didn't know how much of it not
amounting to anything had to do with the
fact that people took it very seriously
I mean that's all together you know you
can never know that but the World Health
Organization the CDC the World Health
Organization coordinated a global
response to figure out what this thing
was very rapidly countries put sometimes
what seemed like maybe draconian
measures into effect very quickly to
stop it spreading know people had the
temperature measured in the airports
people were immediately if they appeared
in the country like in Singapore looking
ill we know whisked off to the hospital
people who were in quarantine were spied
on by neighbors to make sure that they
were you know being staying indoors the
way they were told to so you know there
was a massive reaction but it seems to
work at one point people we know argued
what's it going to be possible to
contain this for the moment they have
whether you know it's going to stay
contained or come back is what people
are now debating but the response i
think you know you could have argued at
any point whether whether or not it was
appropriate but it seems to a work so
I'm thinking retrospect you have to say
what was done was you know was what
needed to be done
Thanks okay because when so then some of
the points going back to West Nile that
you know was very interesting to me mark
who's the co-author in this mark
fischetti did most of the interviewing
but for some reason I got to interview
Marcy Layton who is the unknown
assistant commissioner in the city of
New York health department in the
communicable disease branches so she has
her territory is most communicable
diseases with exception of AIDS and some
other ones that have their own
Department but I got to talk to her and
she told me this story of when these
first cases appeared you know how it
went from somebody going to the hospital
to you know this mobilization of the
whole city against West Nile and it
started out with a physician who was
conscientious and there are a whole list
of diseases and whole list of
circumstances when a physician is
supposed to call into the health
department to tell them that something
unusual is going on or that they have a
case of something rather that's on its
list and you know a lot of times doctors
are too busy and they don't do it but
this one physician Deborah aunt as
missing New York had this I think she
had two cases of encephalitis come in
and she checked and found you know in
neighboring hospitals there was you know
some of her colleagues I don't know and
you know we've had some encephalitis and
normally you might have one or two cases
in a summer and you know it seemed to be
more than there should be and she was
trying to also rule out botulism as a
possible cause so she'd call Marcy
layton and they spoke about what this
might be and Marcy Layton came out and
spoke to you know the patients and their
families trying to understand if there
was anything unusual
on here was this just normal expected
encephalitis or was this something new
and then they started checking around
other hospitals and they found that at
the time that this patient was called in
there was 16 other people in the
hospital who had encephalitis you know
that might not have been picked up and
that was the beginning of the
understanding that something was going
on and we better find out what it was
and then sample started you know flying
to the State Health Department to the
CDC and eventually after a few errors
they you know got it right and figured
out what it was but at the bottom of all
this is you know somebody needing to
recognize that there's something going
wrong not only the patient net port and
Rico could hardly walk so he was wasn't
much of a decision to know that he had
to see a doctor but I mean for the
doctor realize that it was important
take the time to check it out as
something unusual and there's a whole
branch within the CDC called the I think
it's epidemic epidemiology inspections
listen II is something service
epidemiological something service and
it's it's young people out of medical
school would take two years out of their
career to learn how to investigate
outbreaks to find out you know they send
them from the CDC here and there or New
York will have somebody stationed there
to investigate you know find out what
the common denominator is what they
found out about these patients is a lot
of them spent a lot of time outdoors you
know they don't like be out in their
gardens or on their Stoops or whatever
and they went around and inspected
properties and found you know barrels of
rainwater collecting for the garden and
you know they put it together this was
probably a mosquito-borne infection and
before they knew what the virus was they
knew that they had to start spraying for
mosquitoes which is what they did so
again I think that was an important
lesson from West Nile that that it it
takes
you know an alert healthcare providers
to get this whole process started
let's move on to chapter four hmm
chapter four talks about mad cow and
chronic wasting disease how many people
have even heard of chronic wasting
disease a few okay all that many um but
you've all heard of mad cow disease and
tonic and new variant CJD
this is actually again managed to choose
a section that talks about people
figuring out what was going on and the
background to this is of course the the
new in Britain that they had mad cow
disease but when people started coming
down with this in this new variant CJD
they weren't sure if there was
connection and this is part of the
process where they figured that out in
august two thousand the examiners began
to interview relatives of the victims
step by step monk and Brian asked about
a host of standard activities that were
known to cause disease as well as the
novel proposals from researchers one by
one they ruled out possible links among
the victims they didn't all have ferret
bites as kids they had not all eaten
commercial baby food they had different
dentists they weren't all agricultural
workers they received vaccine from
different manufacturers they didn't all
have body piercings or drink from the
same water supply the interviews did
provide a reliable timeframe 1982 1991
was a crucial era during which the
victims would have lived close to one
another more and more factors fell by
the wayside finally a single crate
seemed to link all five victims they ate
beef and their main source of beef in
the 1980s had been local butchers not
supermarkets because in Britain
everybody would be eating beef monk and
Bryant now had to learn all they could
about livestock raising slaughtering and
butch butchering practices what could it
be about beef that might actually cause
a prion disease and people by September
they were talking to people involved in
all the steps in the meat supply chain
it seemed odd in fact suspicious that
the symptoms of cattle with BSE
resembled the symptoms of people with
vCJD the loss of muscle control the loss
of mind was it possible for humans to
succumb to a cow disease and if so why
didn't they die from it back then when
the cows were getting sick okay so prion
zor prions depending on how you prefer
to pronounce it are this very strange
phenomena they're not really infectious
agents they're not organisms in any
sense of the word what they are are miss
folded bits of protein and their
proteins that exist in all of us they're
just an aberrant folded form of a normal
protein that we all make so the prion
doesn't have to reproduce in a sense
that viruses or bacteria reproduce it
doesn't have to create anything from
scratch what it does is it finds a Miss
folded protein finds a normally folded
protein you know snuggles up to it and
gets it to miss form as well so now you
have two of them and then that goes to
start a chain reaction you get more and
more of these miss folded proteins that
eventually form form clumps within the
brain and through a process probably
involving the immune system which may be
mistakes them for some sort of a
threatening microorganism you start
getting these holes in the brain and
it's a very long process and it takes at
least 10 years before between when
somebody first ingests no infected beef
and it turns out just so people don't
you know overreact to the presence of
beef what these investigators found was
that it was in the brain tissue there
was a way of killing cows that high
lying butchers use that involved
hammering something into their brain and
then that's flattering on to the meat is
what caused the disease so if you eat
only you know steaks and hamburgers and
it's prepared properly you know you
don't have to worry about mad cow
disease or this new variant CJD the only
cases in this country and I don't know
if there were one or two and there were
people who spent a long time living in
Britain so there were no as far as
anybody knows any cases in this country
and then there was a recent case of mad
cow disease in Canada that Canada's
still suffering from even though they
slaughtered thousands of other cows and
didn't find
you know from similar from that farm
from other farms where this cow had been
and couldn't find anybody any other cow
with with that disease but nevertheless
the u.s. closed its borders Mexico you
know the whole world essentially stopped
buying Canadian beef and only recently
they've opened the borders but only to
meet that's being sold that's been
butchered so it no longer has any bone
with it and now that's a log back into
this country but the thing is that this
can happen spontaneously I mean it can
happen that protein will miss fold for
all anybody knows this is a single event
in a single cow where this protein just
miss folded leading to disease in that
cow it would never spread to any other
cow it would have to get into this other
cow somehow and Britain it was a matter
of them grinding up the remains of cows
and feeding it to other cows which was
the way its spread when they stop doing
that they stop the spread of both BSE
and this variant CJD ok we have any
quotes started asking about chronic
wasting disease chronic wasting disease
is something that's another prion
disease in this country and it's in deer
and elk Colorado has a lot of its moved
up to Michigan Wisconsin and they're a
few you know hunters who've come down
with some sort of CJD like disease and
you know whether they got it from eating
infected deer elk you know nobody at
this point knows it's something that's
being investigated but what since it's
such a rare event at this point people
are not sure if there's transmission to
humans there's no evidence that there is
it's a possibility justice in Britain
there was no evidence to start with yes
hasn't there been a suggestion that
actually developing um today or symptoms
of that may have a genetic component as
well I mean it may not like you know
they not only would you have to eat
infected beef and the protein would have
to get to the right place and it would
have to do but that somehow there may be
a genetic component to making your
proteins especially bendy or something
um okay cjd exists in various forms and
there is a familial form a genetic form
in which there is some mutation in the
protein that has a tendency to miss fold
and it makes it more likely to miss fold
and people again with that mutation
still don't tend to develop a disease
until they're like in their late 50s or
so so that's one form which is
definitely genetic in Britain it was
found that there was a certain mutation
within that protein that made people
more susceptible now I don't think it
was completely the case that you had to
have that mutation I think it made you
much more likely to get the disease and
overall they were for all the fuss about
that there have been something like 130
deaths these what makes it different
from the familial form where people tend
to be in there least in their 50s is
that in in England a lot of the people
who were dying were in their 20s 30s so
that was one of the clues that this was
something different than they forms they
had they used to we have any any other
questions there okay
our next chapter deals with with e.coli
coli o157 which is one of the forms of
e.coli ecoli is a very common gut
organisms all of us have ecoli living
within our guts without causing any
problems whatsoever but there are mutant
forms of it or they're not exactly
mutants they're their forms of E coli in
the case of o157 which is actually
appropriated a toxin gene from another
organism so that it can now cause a
disease where normally coli doesn't and
it's the organism that's been
responsible for sickening people who eat
undercooked hamburgers started out being
recognized in this country in 1993 with
the jack-in-the-box ins and then people
have heard of and the case that we
talked about is one in actually which
state it was but it was a an outbreak at
a sizzler restaurant chain in which this
three-year-old girl ended up dying and
becoming infected from eating
contaminated water melon somebody had
been using knives to cut contaminated
meat in the kitchen and then use the
same knives to cut the watermelon and
put it out in a salad bar so we have for
this chapter
okay so just very briefly we should be
concerned not only about threats from
exotic foreign diseases and newly
emerging ones the threat from everyday
pathogens all around us right here at
home is at least as great theory they
are evolving rapidly and they can strike
at any time and then we go into the
story of Breanna and we also talked
about this is maybe one of those
chapters where we now get into what you
can do and that involves not only
realizing that you have to you know
maintain good hygiene when preparing
your food and be careful about how you
prepare your food but also to realize
how little the government has been doing
to protect the food supply and how much
some of these meatpacking companies have
gotten away with and by and large it's
the USDA that regulates meet safety it's
been pointed out that they actually have
a conflict of interest because they want
it's their mission and has been for a
longer amount of time to promote
agriculture so they want people to be
buying it's me and then at the same time
they're supposed to be regulating its
safety and so therefore we have attempts
to regulate the cleanliness of plants
but to a large extent what the USDA is
allowed the plans to regulate themselves
and they make them write reports but
they don't do inspections themselves and
they don't close down plants unless the
plant is found to be in violation of
some law and it's fairly difficult to
break these laws so in that case I mean
this is something that's currently going
through Congress discussions about food
safety and what food regulation should
be and how responsible the the meat
packers have to be and whose
responsibility everything is one of the
things being
cerned about bioterrorism people
concerned about meat being imported
across borders because at least in our
country and we have certain amount of
control if it's not perfect we have at
least some control over cleanliness
standards whereas when something comes
from abroad we know nothing about how
you know it was it was prepared but
they're so so with the threat of
bioterrorism meat or any produce
crossing our borders became an issue but
in fact for all the money that's being
spent on border security and
bioterrorism there are fewer inspectors
on our borders nowadays and there used
to be and there was a recent article in
The Globe a few weeks ago about somebody
explaining that they had in their
suitcases something like 300 pounds of
bush meat which are slaughtered monkeys
that they were bringing to some wedding
feast you know and if you're worried
about exotic organisms coming into this
country you know this is you know just
an incredible thing that I mean this
person came forward and explained what
they were doing but apparently there's
one inspector inspecting food that's
being imported that covers all of New
England you know all of our from the
Canadian down to well at least through
Massachusetts and so I mean I think
people in this case not only is there a
personal kinds of efforts that you can
take to protect yourselves but there's
also you know political aspect to this
and people really have to be I think
more active in letting their congressmen
know that they want safe food that it's
not enough to say well if they cook the
hamburgers to the right degree then they
wouldn't be getting sick I mean I don't
think that's you know an appropriate
response which is what you know the meat
industry says it's not really
contaminated if by proper handling you
can get rid of it
it's actually it's getting late why
don't we just stop here and just get a
few questions and yes um would you
comment on the brief report that was in
the press in the past few days that it
turns out that a smallpox vaccination
might actually confirm unity for 75
years up to 75 years I I hadn't seen
that there's some discussion about how
long community lasts and I thought you
know people were arguing whether it was
like 20 years or 30 years it's I hadn't
heard anything about 70 I know that
people who have had smallpox can get it
again many years later but they tend to
get no sense people who've gotten small
packs smallpox vaccine can decades later
get smallpox but they tend to get milder
form so there's some suggestion that
there's some immunity left but you know
it may not be fully protective yes
you're talking about a killer diseases
but could you explain why a disease like
malaria that kills huge amounts of
people where there is the possibility of
drugs so if they were just made
available it would help to eliminate
that particular fear of malaria that
hits so many people and why isn't that
addressed where you're talking about
strains of killer diseases that are
unusual and mutant possibilities but are
really hitting a very small part of our
population now well we also talked about
tuberculosis which is another one of
those killers like malaria which kills
millions of people a year and there are
only recently have people begun to have
this view of the world that says you
know what's happening anywhere in the
world really is should be relevant to us
and malaria is a disease that can be
treated but there is resistance to drugs
it also occurs in places where
healthcare is not readily accessible so
you have to really go out after it the
most effective things that they're doing
you're just giving out netting for
people to put over their beds to keep
them from getting bitten which seems to
be you know what about the level of what
they seem to be able to do have to give
a lot of credit to Bill Gates who comes
into a lot of criticism he and his wife
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation spend
hundreds of millions of dollars for
developing vaccines and finding
treatments for TB AIDS and malaria so
you know there's one person
who is putting you know some of our
governments to shame by showing you know
where his priorities are what he thinks
is important that you people in Africa
deserve whatever protection they can get
as well yes I wondered if you got into
telemedicine at all with the CDC or
other circles when you were discussing
some aspects of controlling or better
responding to unusual presentations of
particular disorders or diseases and as
a way of reaching a rural population
whose physicians may not be as
sophisticated as as physician say in a
large urban center like Boston yeah we
don't get into in any depth we do
mention it telemedicine is this you know
wonderful new ability that we have 22 if
you have a doctor in a rural setting he
can now consult with physicians new in
Boston can have the patient there and
let them see you know what the charts
look like what the x-rays looks like and
get feedback it for some reason I think
partly because of reimbursement issues
it hasn't taken off the way you might
think it should in in terms of
containing a particular outbreak an
early diagnosis would be essential
that's why i was asking about that
because you brought up the cdc now in
terms of outbreaks with SARS the cdc did
a lot of teleconferencing a little bit
different but they did get you know
physicians from you know i don't know
how many different continents and how
many different countries together able
to communicate to share information to
try and figure out what was going on so
that part of it they are doing good
so I go yes one more question last one
bring these things considering that
these things are still comparatively
rare cake compared for example to AIDS
how do you recommend that a limited
government budget be spent among these
various diseases I think we have plenty
of money to spend on diseases I mean
it's all a matter of priorities I got an
email from somebody who would read the
book and said you know he thought
considering what we spend on the
military considering the threat to this
the military threat to this country
compared to a threat from microorganisms
which is much more likely that we should
be spending a lot more of our budget our
national budget on on basic research and
medical research to protect us from from
the very real threat that we face that
really doesn't sound very practical I
don't think we're likely to take a big
chunk of the military budget and switch
it so can you answer the question within
the confines of the kind of money that
we are allowable to spend on disease how
the money should be spent there's these
diseases are doing nothing there was a
vast amount of money that was spent on
that is being spent on bio terrorist
threats the the NIH and the CDC got
billions of additional dollars for
fighting a bioterrorist threat which
again in my mind is it's a real threat
but it's fairly minor in likelihood
compared to the very real threats of the
types of organisms that I'm talking
about it's a matter of I think the
political perception of what people
think needs to be done and if people
were more vocal in letting it be known
that they are concerned about infectious
diseases of all kinds you know
not our job to figure out which disease
gets which money that's what you know
the CDC and the NIH can do if they get
an adequate budget but I think we need
to say that those those organizations
have to be supported that the work they
do is too important to you know make
them have to fight among each other to
try and figure out you know who should
get which penny okay on that note thank
you all very much for coming the new
killer diseases is available from crown
publishing an imprint of Random House
visit their website at Random House calm
/ crown for more information